WE MOVED INTO HER HOUSE,
A MANSION THAT SHE SHARED
WITH SEVERAL FREE-SPIRITED
HOUSEMATES.
- TAYLOR AND SARAH, HI!
- HELLO.
- TOBY.
HE USED TO BE MY KID.
- THAT'S A CHILD--"USED TO BE"?
- HI, GUYS. [laughs]
THIS IS THE SEX TRUCK.
- I'M SORRY, THIS IS
THE SEX TRUCK?
- DR. ERICSON!
- EVERYONE HERE SEEMED
TO HAVE SIGNED ON TO A LIFE
LIVED IN THE HERE AND NOW.
IT WAS IMMEDIATELY OBVIOUS TO ME
THAT THESE WERE MY PEOPLE.
[laughter]
OH, MY.
- I GOT MARRIED!
[laughter]
- OH, YEAH.
- PRETTY BIG NEWS.
- YEAH.
- MAZEL TOV, MAN.
- I SMELL LENTILS.
- THERE WAS A FIRE IN YOUR ROOM.
- FIRE?
- YOUR STUFF'S OUT IN THE YURT.
- COOL.
- OH, STUFF'S OUT IN THE YURT.
GREAT.
SURE.
LOOK AT THAT.
- CAN YOU BELIEVE I FOUND
THIS STUFF ON THE STREET?
- YES, I CAN.
[dog barking]
AS WE SETTLED IN
TO OUR NEW LIFE TOGETHER,
I WAS FILLED WITH A SENSE
OF ANTICIPATION FOR THE FUTURE
I HADN'T FELT SINCE MY YOUTH.
- [sighs]
- OH, UM...
- SWEETHEART?
- [snores]